chaotic and the production manager's
office two years ago construction
materials supplier vo me went bust he
and all the other employees lost their
jobs practically overnight workers like
Marcus and Ignacio and the ranks of the
unemployed I'm still angry at my former
boss but I'm even more angry at the
government it hasn't done anything for
the last two years to help us not a
penny of support we can't expect help
either from our employers or politicians
so it's time for us to take things into
our own hands
back then the huge factory in
Thessaloniki produced mortar and plaster
vo me sold construction materials all
over the Balkans
then came the crisis and the end of the
road but the workers didn't want to
throw in the towel 30 of the company's
80 former employees have continued
operations in this part of the factory
they think their company still has a
future they've begun producing household
detergents and soaps made according to
sustainable principles for minerals they
built the bottle filling machine
themselves
but all their hard work has yet to pay
off I have three children my oldest has
to begin his military service next week
our financial situation is dire
sometimes my parents or my wife's
parents help us out and my wife
fortunately still has a job that's how
we survive Marcus and Ignacio spends his
afternoons on the telephone tirelessly
seeking to sell consignments of soap
through a network of people who
sympathize with the workers situation
promises of solidarity have come in from
all over the world but because the
workers are illegally occupying the
factory investors won't touch the
project the vme workers can't actually
sell their products officially we've
only made a profit with one order we
can't fulfill our dreams with that but
it's enough to keep production up and
running we have to achieve legal status
as a company soon though then we could
hire more of our former colleagues and
increase production levels we'd also
like to branch out into new products too
you know what it's removal and a picture
of the ground immediately
until then the factory workers have to
bring their products to customers
directly residents of Thessaloniki have
been very supportive this woman's
pension has shrunk dramatically but she
exchanges the search she buys for food
we're supporting them as much as we can
they need us then we barter with each
other and the detergents are natural
products
the waterfront promenade in Thessaloniki
Greeks are closing ranks in the midst of
the crisis and Ignacio is joining in a
demonstration to show solidarity with
state broadcaster ERT the government
forced the station to shut down and laid
off 430 staff but employees are
continuing to broadcast over the
Internet like the factory workers at V
AMI
the reporters see themselves as the
vanguard of a new movement a Caravaggio
we've become a symbol for the resistance
movement society is supporting us in a
major way because we're setting an
example so that you can take your
destiny into your own hands
that's why we've invited everyone to
come to this building to talk with us
and learn from us our microphones are
open to everyone
blue tones it no sign of the next
morning the VMA workers are heading to
Thessaloniki courthouse its Court of
Appeals is to rule today on a suit the
workers brought against their former
boss
each is owed about 30,000 euros in
unpaid wages in an earlier decision a
court sentenced the employer to two and
a half years on probation for delaying
bankruptcy proceedings the hearing
doesn't take long the workers still
don't receive any compensation and the
judges even reduce the former employers
sentence lawyers said she had even worse
problems that we have two years ago she
left us all in the lurch and we haven't
seen any money since then now they say
that she's even worse off than we are
everybody is against us the employers
and the government and if the justice
system doesn't protect us anymore either
I don't know where this will all end
the factory workers are outraged but
they're also determined to continue
working in their company now more than
ever